[Music]
in
last straw news last straw
oh how are you doing that's insane
the pure wave one
and i hate it and i could have given it
sounds like that you hate it why
i hate it because i'm too skinny it
hurts my bones stop masturbating with it
then
my bones this is bone yeah oh do you
think she masturbates
smell it what is that is that like a
smell is that like a jigsaw type thing
what is that there it is it goes like
this
it's like this it's a soft fair gun
basically okay okay okay okay
jigsaw it hurts it feels good though i
don't like it you can run
i think i have a pinched nerve you do
those things suck man i've been in pain
since the morning oh take an
elbow because it helped me because i had
a pinched nerve from the flight
it was shooting pains down my legs and
down my arms yeah mine's like shooting
down to my whole
right arm i wanted to cry it hurt so bad
but then advil helped i took a bath
right right during the break i know you
texted me she told me about it she was
like this [ __ ]
wasn't the best did it relax in a little
bit yeah it helped a woman led a protest
after being attacked on the job at
mcdonald's her boss attacked her
customer probably it was the last straw
for this customer
it's a pun because he got upset that
there was no straws
i thought he got the order wrong yeah
like i had six chicken nuggets only got
five
i have never been to a fast food
restaurant when they ran out of straws
well it's not that they ran out or
nothing so there's this new law
in saint petersburg florida
that they said that they will no longer
have straws out in the lobby that people
will need to request it
so they're not just laying out so then
that's what she was trying to explain to
the dude
and then that's when the dude attacked
her oh [ __ ] he just didn't ask for the
straw maybe they ran out i'm not sure
but the point is he was upset about this
new law and he didn't believe that this
new law existed
another customer was filming this whole
thing
damn how does she do that she knows how
to throw
he's trying to run away she won't let
him go
hell yeah [ __ ] little ass [ __ ]
dude that fool did a get over here
he's like
grabbed her ass dude
is he delusional she's dope
so she has some good overhand dude she
went
to her because he thinks because he's a
man and she's a young uh smaller girl he
like has that power to do that i love
this
you got put in her [ __ ] place i love
this [ __ ] cause a lot of chicks
think just because the size difference
they can't do anything she [ __ ] this
dude but you can move fast you can be
aggressive like when some bigger person
or bigger animal [ __ ] with you you just
gotta come back three times harder i saw
that
when she came in close and she started
punching him he let go yeah
no he let go of her neck and then
grabbed her shirt yeah yeah because
watch
look closely where his hand is he pulls
her in from her neck
boom right there you go and then she has
her shirt
element of surprise yeah she's [ __ ]
explosive
he will let go of her yeah she's not
letting go of him now she's pulling him
in
i love that dude good job yeah
good [ __ ] job don't let guys i wonder
if she like
trains a little bit cause her [ __ ]
fists were good
because she didn't she didn't [ __ ] back
like most people did she went from here
to here oh really good a lot of people
don't do that when they throw strikes so
i was like oh maybe she boxes a little
bit she's had a lot of world star
training
yeah did she she unloaded on the
[ __ ] she did like her whole
weight was just like it went from here
to like
bam bam bam yeah one more time one more
time
satisfying when the prey becomes the
predator i
love that [ __ ] last three word phrase
was the best
and then he starts trying to say like i
was just trying to talk to you
am i choking her question i hate you
yeah
look at that yeah you can't do that yeah
oh
boom oh you [ __ ] up look at those hits
those are good dude
that guy's just laughing he's trying to
pull her off but he's laughing
but then it took him like a few seconds
to even intervene
too like she was well i don't want none
of that [ __ ] either that's why andy
she's probably caught off guard like
oh [ __ ] it didn't register yeah she
moved
fast man it took like about eight
seconds before
anyone started touching dude how strong
is she that
his upper body could not get away from
her like he was like
oh [ __ ] she has a gravitational pull
he looked like a kid with this shirt
about to come off he couldn't run away
even if he tried
amazing i'm inspired i love that dude
let's put her to youtube
so crazy that he thought that she was
just attacking him i know
he's just a [ __ ] he's like when he got
called out he didn't expect to get
[ __ ] hit so he was just like oh and
then now i'm gonna he's like crazy
yeah he's just gonna like [ __ ] pull
up and do that now they start
playing the victim card yeah he's asking
questions
i want her fired right now if like i'm
trying to figure out when people do
these things
what do they when you do something like
this there has to be a next step
what was the exit plan after you after
you choked her right probably thought
that she was gonna submit
and that he was gonna have her his way
and then he was gonna be the big tough
guy and no one's gonna mess with him
everyone's gonna clap
oh yeah like oh yeah you stood your
ground that was his ex
manly man he did not expect for that
plot twist [ __ ] golden gloves
champion and [ __ ]
and i'm actually writing in the article
hailed as some kind of boxing star
i'm so surprised the guys didn't come in
and start punching a guy in the face
right they didn't need to well why did
they need to step in
she had she handled that [ __ ] actually
because his self-defense thing was
blocking the hits with his face
you know not that she needed the help
just it makes me angry
like if my co-worker was being attacked
if she's my friend then it's like
i gotta get it i think by the time that
they reacted to it though like she
already had it pretty handled and it was
like one of those things i don't think
he was
beat enough that's my problem yeah yeah
so her name is there's no blood
there's no knockout there's no real
punishment i'm surprised he wasn't like
her skinny homie that came from behind
smiling he was like oh [ __ ] better wait
pulled her off
wait this isn't working let me walk
around and pull him off yeah he like
walks around the other side
because she was too strong for him yeah
all right so yes being here she's a 20
year old
uh gangster boxing champ
yeah happy meals for a lifetime yeah so
the man
is now facing two separate assault
charges yes
yep nice so this is what i hope he gets
jail time he looks like
oh he's smiling i think he's crazy oh
all that nothing he's younger than i
thought
he looks like florida man i thought he
was like 70 from that thing yeah
he looked like an old like 50 year old
man or something he looks like he likes
to eat
meth for lunch it led to
like her leading a protest against
mcdonald's well so she was
saying like you know they need to have
better practices
and try to fight to end workplace
violence
and like they need to step up the
training to protect its employees
and they must deal with a lot of [ __ ]
then because i'm sure this isn't the
only time that she's just
she's probably gonna deal with this a
lot yeah she's like what the [ __ ] man
like i just dealt with this [ __ ] like
two hours ago
oh remember freaking uh the other girl
andre the giant where she beat up that
girl
oh yeah that wasn't a mcdonald's yeah
mcdonald's too she [ __ ] that girl
up dude her titty flopped out and
everything that was las vegas
i think the scum of the earth just goes
to mcdonald's that's why i mean i like
mcdonald's
me too i mean i go there too that's why
you know what though it's a lot of
fast food and especially near the uh
freeways they they face a lot of
violence because robberies happen so
it's not just our lovely mecha days my
friend worked at a
quiznos and you would say like that
plaza yeah it's right next to the
freeway
so they would get robbed like right when
closing time comes
people will come and just point a gun at
them yeah or like
the starbucks right next to them they'll
just be guys waiting
and then like they'll catch an employee
and then they'll send like have a card
that says like
i have a gun give me money and then like
they'll discretely get money and walk
away
or like there's just crazy [ __ ] that
goes down slide a [ __ ] note back that
just says
not today [ __ ] what do you mean
it's with all the money in it there's a
photo from that
gathering so it's called hashtag last
straw movement
and so they're just funny you should
probably name it something else
that's hilarious who who's the girl that
fought this girl wants
yeah she look for real look at that
forehead that's a serious ass forehead
she's gonna [ __ ] somebody up
i've seen um security guards at like
more more dangerous uh restaurants
though
which like fast food places yeah she got
[ __ ] pythons too there's one
at the mcdonald's near our downtown
office oh that one's a little sketchy
even after the remodel i'm like no i'm
not going there oh yeah so they're even
interviewing like one of the attendees
another mcdonald's employee from a
different part of florida and she went
over because she was like
just wanting to show support for her
like fighting back and like also
the fact that there was someone there to
record all this and like have her back
because if that lady that customer that
wasn't there then they wouldn't have
that angle that caught like you know him
immediately going after and like
attacking her first yeah one of the
attendees she was saying that she
was suffering from like horrifying
nightmares after one of her co-workers
was
arrested on four murder charges in 2017.
oh my god don't they have a background
check
we talked about this on jk news too and
so like she worked several shifts with
him and so she would ask mcdonald's like
you know like i i need help talking to
someone about this because it's so
traumatizing
because she worked just under the
threshold for
the benefits with the restaurant to come
in like so she had to go through
her like a different insurance and so
she was saying like you know that's like
mcdonald's needs to be better about
providing i agree resources to their
employees
i specifically agree because they have
sponsored everybody you know what they
need to do
they need to get ronald mcdonald to
train jiu jitsu
can you imagine him in a jiu jitsu i'm
trying to imagine this dude
ronald mcdonald yeah that'd be dumb
shoes
yeah the playpen turned that area into
an mma pit
yeah sell tickets yeah that'd be so cool
and then like all the employees get to
learn self-defense what great
self-defense for her because right when
you grab
her it was game over good instincts man
she was like i don't know what to do
i'ma [ __ ] you up
like that was that was it i would have
reacted way slower like pull forward all
the way what the [ __ ] is going on right
now yeah i've been trying to get his
number [ __ ] also give me your contact
real quick
like no sir that's the law i'm telling
you that is the law
that's the law or in the back
i keep telling you that's what i would
do i think
because if i'm in like work mine i'm not
thinking about fighting until like
that just goes to show how many times
she had to deal with that to the point
where she was ready yeah
yeah that's why it's the last straw yep
she's saying
[Music]